france borders eight countries
well actually no it doesn't it borders
way more than eight countries
and in fact its longest border isn't
even this one with belgium
or this one with spain it's this one way
over here with brazil
[Music]
what is going on here i learned this on
reddit and it quickly flung me down
a giant rabbit hole of some very strange
information
i then put a call out on instagram and
asked
all of you to tell me what is going on
with france and
its giant overseas empire looking thing
i got a bunch of responses
so then i did what i always do which is
spent the entire day
mapping this every single island every
single administrative boundary every
single ocean border i made an entire
behind the scenes by the way for my
patrons thank you patrons
you guys rock yeah it was a lot but now
i'm on the other side of it
and i have some stuff to share with you
[Music]
by the way this video is sponsored by
storyblocks where i get a lot of amazing
footage
more on that later
okay so this is france but really this
is only one
version of france they call this version
of france
lexogon or the hexagon it's also called
la france metropol
or the metropolitan france it's the
mainland it's the motherland of france
the france you probably think of when
you think of france here in europe but
there's another
france it's called france dolce mae or
the
overseas france and that one looks like
this
this france accounts for almost 20 of
all of france's land and a whopping 97
of its ocean territory nearly 3 million
french citizens live here
this france is peculiar it includes
far-flung tropical islands
remote archipelagos with penguins and
weird-looking
uninhabited atolls all around the world
there's lobster fishing and scientific
research and nuclear weapons
testing and military exercises and the
mind-blowing fact
here is that because france actually
looks like this that means that the
european union
actually looks like this
i want to show you france's weirdest
borders and pieces of land
to try to understand why this country
that should have decolonized six
centuries ago has territory all around
the world
all right so let's go over to the
netherlands no no not
that netherlands let's go this way over
to the caribbean this is
a little island that is split in half
between the netherlands
and france it's the only place where
these two countries share a border
the population here they're french
citizens a few years back they did vote
to become semi-independent from france
but even still the french citizens this
is france
zoom out and you'll see that france
isn't alone this whole neighborhood is
full of european colonial holdovers
france has three other island groups in
this chain
two of which are basically the exact
same as mainland france
in their administrative status and then
you get down here to france's longest
border
which is in french guiana which is a
proper part of france and the european
union and the eurozone
they use the euro here but remember
where we are we're in south america
this place was used as a prison colony
for france most of the time
a lot of people were sent here for
grueling prison sentences
many died that's a whole other history
we're not going into it
okay so this is french guyana and the
caribbean key part of france honestly
people just like to vacation here
because they speak french
and it looks like this
[Music]
anyway let's zoom up north to a teeny
tiny island that is a holdover from
the old days when france was colonizing
north america this little piece
of france is 4 000 kilometers from
france metropol but it is a few
kilometers off the coast of canada
and it's right smack dab in the middle
of canadian
economic waters france wanted to hold on
to this and have it as their own little
enclave away from france and so a few
years ago they
fought with canada in the international
courts to try to carve out a little bit
of economic waters for themselves that
looked like this
turns out they ended up only getting
this little key shaped slice
of economic waters so that they could
have a little passageway
into their country from international
waters
to their little france enclave and
that's what it looks like today it's a
super weird situation here on this
island they use the euro
and they speak french like france french
not
quebec french it is a very french place
even though it is
right smack dab in the middle of
canadian waters okay so the caribbean
and this weird set of islands off of
[Music]
canada
[Music]
now let's get to the wild ones the ones
that were actually the hardest for me to
get my head around as i was mapping them
[Music]
if you zoom all the way down here close
to antarctica all of
these islands are owned by france
there are people who live on these
islands who are french citizens
we'll get to those in a second but first
look at this weird looking block
i know it's a little bit awkward thanks
mercator let's
look at it a little bit differently here
from like an actual bottom up view
this slice of land is claimed by france
a frenchman arrived here in the 1800s
and claimed it for france
and they've had people there ever since
that's a literal ice wall even in the
1800s they knew that there was an ice
wall
the world is flat okay so france claims
this little bit of antarctica
zoom up just a little bit and you'll get
to all these french islands that have
a ton of inhabitants but they're just
not humans
[Music]
there were more king penguins on these
islands than anywhere else in the world
and honestly looking at photos of these
islands makes me feel like this is the
part of france i want to visit more than
any part of france
i mean look at this place
and the crest for this group of islands
the official crest
is like really cool looking i mean it's
got lobsters
and seals that are like yelling and
king penguins i mean this place is just
a wild freaking
dreamland the only actual people who
live on these islands are french
military and science personnel so why
did france hold on to
these remote islands near antarctica and
these ones here in the indian ocean well
other than the fact that france is
as our friend cgp grey notes the queen
of not letting go
these islands provide france with a
major presence in the indian ocean
military presence where they can put
bases they can run patrols
they can just have a presence in this
important geopolitical part of the world
here are the french military activities
in the region between 2016 and 2019.
you can see how these islands give
france immense military presence in the
region
okay wait i'm just trying to do like a
fun geography explainer i don't need to
get into like the military stuff can we
just
chill out for just one video can i just
not explain the geopolitics
sure but don't forget that these islands
are also used to harvest over
16 million euros worth of fish and
lobster
okay stop i get it military dominance
resource extraction science
stuff i get it but wait while we're here
i also want to mention that during the
60s and 70s
france literally stole hundreds of
children from this
island one of their territories to bring
back to france to help boost the
declining rural population
okay that's actually pretty f um yeah
okay so zoom to another really remote
part of the ocean this time the pacific
ocean so
the most remote ocean in the world and
you will see
a bunch of teeny tiny islands that are
france they are 14 000 kilometers from
france metropole
which is like a half a planet away like
they're so remote
and to understand why france wants to
hold on to these islands just look at
the water boundaries
the water boundaries of these 118
islands of french polynesia
are five million square kilometers for
context the entire european union
like the land mass the area of the whole
eu is 4.4 million
square kilometers so the water
boundaries around
french polynesia are huge it is a lot of
water that belongs to france
this place is home to bora bora and
tahiti
and just a bunch of really beautiful
islands so maybe i take back my previous
statement
this is the part of france i want to
visit the most
but wait aren't you forgetting something
yes i'm sure i'm forgetting something
french polynesia
is where france tested its nuclear
weapons
almost 200 of them between the 1960s and
1990s
damaging local populations and natural
environments
and violating international law yes of
course
nukes in the pacific ocean damaging
irreparably
populations and natural resources i
guess i should have known i should know
sorry just trying to do a geography
explainer that's all
right let's look at one last piece of
overseas france
which is right next to french polynesia
but let's zoom to the other side of the
map so we can see it better
this is new caledonia and they were
actually on their way out
of being a part of france they were on a
20-year plan to transfer power
completely
to the people of new caledonia but just
last month
just like literally a few weeks ago they
voted on this the people voted and
53 percent of them said they wanted to
stay with france
well 47 percent wanted independence
voters on the pacific islands of new
caledonia
have once again rejected independence
from france france secretly
loved this decision because new
caledonia is full of
nickel something they could mine the
result was welcomed by france's
president emmanuel macron there you go
with your natural resources again and
honestly
this vote of new caledonia wanted to
stay with france gets to the heart
of the tension in all of these colonial
holdovers
all of these islands are the product of
french colonialism
brutal greedy racist colonialism
the people in these countries were
conquered and ruled by this ruthless
power
who forced them to adopt their language
their government
and their economic structures and yet
here we are
centuries later in a globalized economy
where the world governmental
order and system was invented by these
big colonizing powers the frances the
britons of the world france holds on to
all of these islands because of what we
just talked about military interests
expanding their economic waters
scientific research
exploiting natural resources and so now
you have many locals
who live under france's rule and many
want
independence but others realize that
there are benefits
to being attached to the people who
invented the rules and who still have
the power
that is not an easy tension to resolve
for now
things likely won't change this is
france and will probably be france for a
long time
they will keep their sprawling low-key
empire around the world and france's
longest border will continue to be
not with belgium or spain but with
brazil
[Music]
telling stories like this is a visual
puzzle because
obviously the mapping and the technical
part but also just being able to bring
you to these places and bring myself to
these places as i'm researching it is
hard
i lean on a lot of different resources
and one of the major resources i lean on
is storyblocks who is the sponsor of
today's video some of the footage that
you saw in this piece like this clip
and this clip and this clip those were
all downloaded
from storyblocks i didn't pay any extra
to get these clips i pay one
subscription and i have unlimited access
to over a million
assets a lot of that high quality 4k
beautiful footage
i can download as much of this as i want
every month that i'm a member i also get
access to
after effects templates and audio
resources like sound effects
it is a tool in my toolkit that i don't
know what i would really do without i've
been using storybox for years well
before they ever came to sponsor a video
and i can't recommend them enough
if you are someone who is trying to tell
stories or
improve your skills as a video maker or
someone who
needs high quality assets for
professional video making honestly i use
this for all of my
projects and i am very grateful to
storyblocks for supporting this channel
there is a link in my description
clicking that link helps support this
channel
but it also gives you a way to find out
more on how you can
get access to all these amazing assets
for a very very affordable price
it actually sort of blows my mind like
compared to all other stock footage
which is
usually very expensive for just one clip
and you pay by the second
with storybox you pay one price and you
get access to all of it unlimited
so i don't really know how it works but
it does work and i use it all the time
so
thank you storyblocks thank you all for
being here thank you patrons for
supporting this channel as well
i was able to do a behind the scenes of
my map workflow for patrons i'm also
outputting a high-res
version of this france map that is on
patreon as well
so go check that out thank you all for
being here and i hope you're having a
great
end of your 2020 and i will see you
in 2021 bye
[Music]